alors une odyssée qui se termine donc
bien ce soir françois corner vous êtes
sur place à orly et vous avez à vos
côtés le commandant de bord du boeing
d'air france oui le commandant de bord
et le copilote les héros bien bien
humble ici à leur arrivée à paris alors
commandant la première question qu'on a
envie de vous poser
que ressentez-vous alors que cette
histoire maintenant est terminée mais
nous sommes surtout très heureux d'être
revenu en france après un voyage qui au
départ nous paraît très très routinier
c'est qui qui sérieuse est plutôt mon
devoir
quel a été le moment le plus difficile
le plus tendu de ce voyage il serait
difficile de dire quel était le moment
le plus difficile parce qu'un 48 heures
nous avons eu plusieurs moments où la
tension a été extrême et à choisir un
en particulier serait vraiment très
difficile c'est plutôt un père hanks a
été pendu plutôt qu'ailleurs
attirant surtout au dernier moment juste
avant qu'on peut le libérer
ce qui est malgré le tassement
très courte est-ce que vous avez cru un
moment donné que les pirates de l'air
allait mettre leur menace à exécution
c'est à dire aller tuer des otages ou
innovantes
et lorsqu'ils ont tendu leurs leur fils
reliés aux pains de plastique qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé à ce moment là
qu'ils allaient faire sauter l'avion
avec vous à l'intérieur il y à un point
qui n'est pas encore éclaircie une
question tout le monde se pose à propos
des armes à feu au départ semble-t-il
les pirates n'étaient équipées que
d'armes blanches et les armes à feu
ensuite ont fait leur apparition qu'en
est il exactement
non non pas du tout aux dépens d'équipés
de devant ils donnent une très grande
quantité de bombes artisanales avec une
bêche et détonateur
d'armes blanches que vous avez juste de
kotoko tour
et à quel moment les armes à feu ont
elles fait leur apparition
bien jeu
je pense que c'est un peu notre régate
et en quelques cas qui ont marqué le
rail la terre
est-ce que vous avez une idée dans la
fin de la façon dont les pirates se sont
procurés césar mais ce qu'elle était en
soute ou est-ce qu'elles sont venues
autrement nous ne l'avons absolument
aucune idée
de la conforte dans notre milieu
je crois que c'est vous qui avez co
pilote qui avait décollé l'avion de
beyrouth et s'était semble-t-il un peu
dur non non ce n'était pas vraiment ça
s'est passé ce décollage de beyrouth
dont on a tant parlé non en fait c'est
le collage et et acrobatique
il est vraiment dangereux
il est réalisable nous l'avons invalides
hervé je ne sais pas si vous avez une
question à poser au commandant de bord
ou aux copilotes
oui françois j'aimerais demander au
commandant si il a eu l'impression que
les autorités iraniennes pendant cette
affaire quand le boeing était à téhéran
si les autorités iraniennes se sont
montrés à son avis complaisante
vis-à-vis des pirates ou nous alors je
sers de traducteurs pour le présentateur
puisque j'ai l'oreillette découdre avec
l'autre demande si vous pensez
que les autorités iraniennes ont se sont
rendus complices des pirates ou au
contraire est-ce qu'elles sont restés
très en dehors de cette affaire
pas du tout apparemment les autorités
iraniennes n'était pas comprise ont été
pires mois quand on est sur place carnot
parce que je pense que vous aurez qui
ont servi d'intermédiaire pour les
négociations qui ont eu lieu
je ne pensais pas qu'il y avait de
complicité quelconque
apparemment non
voilà il y avait je sais que le journal
n'est pas terminée si vous avez une
dernière question imposé nous avons
encore le commandant de bord à nos côtés
sinon je vous rend l'antenne
merci françois nous vous retrouverons
bien sûr dans nos éditions de la matinée
demain matin merci commandant